コンビニよく行かれますよね？
えー
コンビニよく行くと思うんですけれども
まぁよく飲む飲み物は何ですか？
コーラって言って…
コーラ
よくお口直しに食べるものは何ですか？
ブレスケア…
そぉ何ですよ！
んー。
その２つの組み合わせって やっぱり
異色だと思うんですよね！
まぁ中々無いですわな
あれ嚙むと多分知らない人いると思うんですけど
あれってっけこう口臭治しって言って
こうミントの香りが凄いんですよ！
それを
コーラのシュワシュワ感を合わせると
(はじめんの変顔入りました)
ビックな
バンが
ハハハハハ
まぁまぁ
よう訳しよう
はい
とりあえずノリ君が今回ちょっと
面白い話をもってきてて
こぅえ…ブレスケアを全部食べた後に
コーラを飲むと？
何かが起きる？
だからそれをなんか、それを今回、今日は
試してもらおーかなって
やってまいりました
いいネタだよ
極めて良いネタ
なんか多分予想なんですけど
メントスコーラ的なイメージだと勝手に
思っている私は
あゝ成程ね！
チッチッチ(なんかムカつくｗ)
アマいですね!
ぁ//
はいというわけでコーラとブレスケア準備しました
で、通常のブレスケアとは違って
これ最大量のミントなんですyo!
もうブレスケア史上最大と言われてるやつなんで
滅茶苦茶つよいです！
❓¿❔¿？
50粒あります‼
ぉぉぉぉお
どうしたどうした⁉
ぁあそこそこ入ってますねでも⤵⤵
これしかもホントは噛まないんですyo!
ぁあホントだ‼
水などの飲み物と
一緒に飲みこんで下さいって書いてあります
これ極めて危険んな気がするな。。
これ1回の目安量３粒って書いてあるんん/のに...。
全部ってことでしょ？
はい。
終わるよ？(また)
フハハハハハ(意味深)
こ，怖
恐、恐恐っ
噛まずに飲むんですけど、
今回は、全部噛んでもらいます(⌒∇⌒)
噛んで全部食べてもらいますこれは！
その後に飲んでもらいます
コーラの飲む量は？
それはもう…いやもう分かります
飲んだ瞬間に
ぁあそういう系ね(どういう系?)
はい。
やろうじゃないの‼
アハハハハ
っと僕は、何も知らない
マジかますからな!!go
なんか昔ね～やったことあんだyo¡
１０００粒食べてみたみたいな
あ、やってましたよね～
非常にきつかったからな
じゃ、全部噛みます
ゴリゴリ言ってる
ぉおおおおお！
きたきた
この時点でやばい
なんか、ぁぁあ
ホント喋れないんだよこれ
あ、ダメダメダメ
いった、はやくはやく
飲んで飲んで飲んで
さぁどうなるか？
どうぞ
ぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁあ!!!!!
ノリさんの笑い声。
もう一回確かめていい？
これ凄いね
凄くないですか？
のど越しが痛い
凄いですよね
イタイイタイ痛いわ！
(なぜ飲む⁉)
痛いね
凄くないですか？
(だからなぜ飲むんだ⁉)
ヤバいわ！
結構危険ですよこれ
結構危険だね
も、もう、し、心拍数も上がってきますもんね
汗が止まんない
(いや、だからなぜ飲む⁉)
のどが渇いてどうしても
飲んじゃうんですよ(成程)
飲んで結局なっちゃうっていう繰り返しなんですよ
これ実はカラクリで
い、痛かったっす　マジで
コーラとブレスケアはホント
相性悪いか分かんないですけど
凄い痛かったし
凄い爽快感が凄かったので
皆さん、痛いんで※マネしないようにしてください
ノリ君……。
ノリ君!?!?
ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓
(諦めた…)
ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺッ!!!!